if he's found on any one of these
charges it is thought that he could go
to jail for 10 to 20 years so if any one
of about 20 21 22 charges he
could be spending the rest of his life
in jail and we've got use over the years
to just Trump all this legal palava it
just drags on and he always gets away
with it I think there is some Justified
excitement from all the people that hate
Trump that this may be his final undoing
because he does appear to behave very
recklessly with these documents there
are reports again it's a lot of you have
to be very careful what you say because
a lot of it is motivated by people who
desperately want to bring him down but
there's a lot of talk about how he used
to show off about the documents tell
people what was in them even show people
the documents and you can sort of
Imagine Trump doing that that's quite a
trump thing to do to say look I've got
these secret files on Aliens so I think
this may it's possible this may be the
thing that gets drunk